moi je me suis dit virginie efira un
projet comme ça puisque est un acteur
normalement un acteur est quand même un
ego qui est compliqué chez les jeunes en
plus
parce qu'avec le réseauteur on savait
pas très bien qui prendrait tout ça et
puis on se dit tiens où les gens ne le
connaissent pas terminé mais commence
mais c'est le frein c'était un frein
pendant tout le match tryba du tueur ait
perdu c'était horrible j'ai pas trop
comment on a fait pour bosser c'était
l'enfer non ça s'est passé on ne peut
mieux on était sur la même longueur
d'onde et puis elle a un truc je peux
importe depuis bien elle est généreuse
et pour moi c'est juste la plus belle
rencontre que j'ai fait d'une actrice
sur un plateau de cinéma
on était mort de rire tous les jours tu
es super en forme que jamais cette
émission c'est parce qu'il était
d'accord avec ça mais c'est une sorte de
métaphore sur le mot crise est l'icône
ou les aligne déjà que métaphore merci
j'ai mis à tous les deux toute équipe ii
disait d'ailleurs c'est quand même
deux personnes qui étaient un peu alors
pourquoi peut refermer qui remet à vide
et je pense qu'on a des qualités et
voilà